Mark Twain once said the difference
between the almost right word and the
right word is the difference between the
lightning bug and the lightning same
thing happens with photography when you
combine the right words the right
pictures the Right Moving Pictures with
the right music and the right story you
have a recipe for being able to get into
a person's brain and change not just the
way they think but the way they act you
know the first film we do is the cove
and it's about dolphin hunting and when
we did that film they were killing
23,000 dolphins some purposes every year
in Japan for human consumption and the
last year I looked it was like two years
ago I think they killed 1610 so it's
down over 93% since we started that film
so films are very very powerful weapons
for for social change and that's why I
do what we're doing we had you know
rickle telling rickle Berry story had a
profound effect on that industry